the u.s navy has officially launched a
ship named after harvey milk a
controversial political activist who
preyed on troubled teen boys and who
defended jim jones another sexual
predator who became one of the most
infamous murderous cult leaders in
american history to top it all off the
official ceremony was presided over by a
man who thinks he's a woman
paula would you please christen the
of the united ship of america
i christen the harvey milk
may god bless the ship and all who sail
in here
[Music]
the usns harvey milk if you think we're
living in clown world you're right i'm
sure our enemies overseas have noticed
that too i'm always trying to look for
the silver lining in things i mean this
is this is pretty bad our country is
extremely confused we're being
humiliated to our adversaries overseas
but on the bright side of this harvey
milk ship announcement
the navy recruitment ads are are about
to get way catchier
[Music]
sign up for the big
[Music]
[Music]
i guess this has been a long time coming
you know and frankly frankly
if the navy were to use the village
people as their recruitment ad
they would basically just be doing what
the army and the cia are already doing
with with their super woke
recruitment ads this is pretty
pretty weird folks the other thing with
harvey milk by the way what you're going
to hear about harvey milk he was a gay
rights pioneer
he was murdered
martyred really for his sexual desires
and that's not true harvey milk was
killed he was killed along with the
mayor of san francisco by a disgruntled
former colleague this guy dan white who
was upset that he wasn't being paid
enough money to support his family he
just went in and went postal one day in
city hall and he happened to find harvey
milk and he killed him and he killed the
mayor he was not
killed for his sexual desires but
but
the truth will be made to fit the
narrative here okay
that's the power of narrative harvey
milk was a degenerate i mean this guy
would prey on homeless runaway young
boys well below the age of consent and
he would he would
he was a sexual predator toward them he
was a great defender of jim jones who
killed all those people in guyana by
making them all literally drink the
kool-aid that's where the expression
comes from he was defending him to
president jimmy carter i mean he was
just
he was not a good guy okay he was not a
good guy at all
but any and then he was martyred but he
wasn't even killed for his sexual desire
even but it doesn't matter the reality
of harvey milk will be wiped away will
be completely transformed for the
narrative of liberation specifically for
the narrative of sexual liberation which
we're now told is one of the most
important themes in american history
it's being able to sleep with whomever
you want being able to identify with
whatever sex you want being able to
invent a bunch of new genders and this
has now affected the military navy jokes
aside this is this is a new
advancement of radicalism in the navy
thanks for watching that vid man i'm
glad you liked that if you want all of
the cool vids and clips and episodes
full-length episodes ring that bell
subscribe here on youtube sometimes our
overlords on this platform don't like to
send the notifications so if you want to
be sure to get the full uncensored show
all the time head on over to apple
podcast spotify stitch or google play
subscribe to the michael knowles show
leave a five star review we'll see you
next time
[Music]
[Music]
you